all right only 32 days until the
all-important midterm elections
Republicans now rallying behind the
agenda that they will enact if they can
flip one or both chambers of Congress
now House Republicans have released
their commitments to America Kevin
McCarthy has promised that the house
resolution number one will be a repeal
of of the funding for 87 000 new IRS
agents to harass you now other
Republicans are also promising immediate
oversight of the IRS including
investigation delays in issuing tax
refunds for example in the city of Ted
Cruz Lindsey Graham they are putting
Homeland Security secretary mayorkas on
notice that he could face impeachment if
the situation at the border does not
improve soon and significantly and while
Senator Cruz is predicting a wet red
tsunami in November that's only going to
happen if all of you everybody turns out
to vote 132 days and that's why he is
now on a 17 State bus tour barnstorming
the country for Republican candidates
and Texas Senator Ted Cruz joins us now
he's in Utah tonight uh Senator great to
have you by the way I I noticed one
thing that's going on in Utah I want to
point this out is a fortune is coming
from outside of the state in these smear
attacks a lot of slander against Senator
Mike Lee who's done a phenomenal job a
true constitutionalist like yourself
and this guy
we call him Egg McMuffin Evan McMullen
uh is out there pretending to be
something that he's not he is a Romney
Republican and I hope the people of Utah
are smart enough to understand
well look you're exactly right this race
here in Utah Mike Lee unfortunately has
a real race I'm here campaigning for
Mike Mike is is phenomenal I believe
Mike Lee is one of the greatest Senators
ever to have served in the United States
Senate he is brilliant he's a
constitutional scholar he is a Fierce
and ferocious fighter over and over
again for a decade Mike and I have been
side by side shoulder to shoulder
fighting to defend Freedom defend the
Constitution and to urge our own party
to stand up and actually do what we
promise to do and I'll tell you here in
Utah the Democrats are doing something
really deceptive and dishonest the
Democrats have not run a quote Democrat
candidate they decided not to nominate
anyone at all instead you've got
McMuffin who is theoretically running as
an independent but he's running as an
independent the Democrat Party in Utah
has endorsed him they are raising
millions of dollars for him through act
blue the same entity they use to support
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and
AOC into funnel cash into the race he
voted for Joe Biden he supports Joe
Biden's policies amazingly enough
McMuffin also said he would support S1
which is Schumer's number one priority
the corrupt politicians act that would
essentially strike down every voter
Integrity law across the country it
would strike down photo ID requirements
it would strike down prohibitions on
ballot harvesting it would automatically
register millions of illegal aliens to
vote and and it would strike down
prohibitions on felons voting because
apparently the Democrats think we need
more murderers and rapists choosing our
leaders
this race what makes it dangerous is
they're counting on Deception their
their objective is to win all the
Democrats and just a handful maybe five
ten percent of the Republicans who are
not paying much attention and say gosh
isn't he a nice guy no he is a not not a
nice guy when he is complicit in the
cultural marxists that are doing damage
to this country that is massive so I
want to encourage your viewers go
support Mike Lee go to Mike Lee's
website make a contribution support him
I'm here campaigning for him because he
needs to win and if people hear the
truth Mike will win decisively but this
is a close and a real race
listen we're also in play in Nevada I
think laxal can win uh Blake Masters had
a great debate uh General Bulldog now
within the margin of era in New
Hampshire we've got to play there
Tiffany Smiley who would have thought
Patty Murray would be vulnerable in fact
she is uh then of course Ron Johnson JD
Vance uh Dr Oz uh Herschel Walker yes um
I'm not that worried about Senator
Kennedy or Rand Paul or uh Tim Scott in
South Carolina but you know what I don't
take anything for granted where do you
see this coming down at the end of the
day will Republicans do you believe they
will get control of the Senate
so I do I think we're going to win both
houses I'd put the chances of our
winning the house at north of 90 percent
I think there's a real chance we don't
just win the house but we win with a big
majority something like 50 but 30 40 50
seats in the Senate I'd put the odds of
our winning the Senate at about 65-35 I
think we're about a two to one favorite
to win if you ask me to pick a number
I'd predict that we come out at 53
Republicans and and you mentioned that
I'm in the middle of a month-long
17-state bus tour so we started seven
days ago we started in Tomball Texas
just north of Houston we went down to
the Rio Grande Valley we did rallies in
McAllen and Harlingen and Laredo then we
went to New Mexico did a big rally there
then we went to Arizona did two rallies
there in Tucson and Phoenix then we went
to Nevada did a big rally in Las Vegas
now we're in Utah from Utah we go on to
Missouri and Kansas and Iowa and Ohio
Ohio and Pennsylvania and Virginia and
North Carolina and Tennessee and Georgia
and Florida and then back up to Michigan
back up to Wisconsin and we close it out
back in the great state of Texas all in
all we're supporting 35 candidates in 25
stops in 17 States and I got to tell you
Sean we're seeing energy we're seeing
passion people are ready to throw these
lunatics out who have done so much
damage to the country I think we're
going to see an historic election in
November Ted Cruz will be checking in
all throughout your tour thank you for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else